ça ah bah oui tu bien sûr je sais bah
oui donc c'est pour ça regardz ça va
être un truc de fou voilà donc vous
voyez bien qu'on va le diffuser et
franchement j'ai envie de regarder ah
franchement ça va être ça va être un
carton c'est très fort bravo tu tu es tu
es un chef franchement tu es un patron
tu es un patron tu es un patron on va
revenir sur une histoire hallucinante
c'est l'histoire de claudune femme de 84
ans qui promenait son chien dans un parc
Anice le 24 janvier dernier lorsque
soudain une jeune femme lui a sauté
dessus et AA agressé violemment
aujourd'hui son pronostic vital est
engagé sa fille sandra est avec nous ce
soir pour pousser un cri du cœur écouez
cette histoire tout le monde en a parlé
c'est une histoire de fou et l'agresseur
apparemment est dehors je ver alle nous
en parler vous allez voir vous allez
dire on marche sur la tête encore
regardez mercredi dernier c'est un
terrible fait d'hiver qui s'est déroulé
dans la ville de Nice une octogénaire
rouée de cou alors qu'elle promenait son
chien la dame de 84 ans croise une jeune
femme qui promène elle aussi son animal
à quatre PES très vite et dans des
circonstances floues l'octogéère est
alors violemment agressé par la jeune
femme et se retrouve plaquée au sol
conduite aux urgences son pronostic
vital est aujourd'hui engagé et sa fille
sandra est dévasté elle lui a volé sa
fin de vie gratuitement le cré du cœur
de sa fille ce soir dans TPMP je
remercier Sandra d'être avec nous ce
soir et Sandra on a tous été choqué par
ce qui s'est passé pour votre maman à
qui on pense très très fort Claude 84
ans violemment agressé est-ce que vous
pouvez nous raconter ce qui s'est passé
raconter à nos téléspectateur à 20h58 en
direct ce qui s'est passé pour votre
maman parce qu'on est tous concernés et
on est tous les enfants et les petits
enfants de Claude ce soir bien sûr
dites-nous donc ma ma mère était eu
alors attendez je vois voir si votre
micro marche bien si vous plaî si on
peut mettre des micros qui marchent aux
invités merci ce serait important merci
donc allez allez-y donc ma mère est une
une petite mamie qui va comme tous les
matins promener son petit chitsou à côté
de chez elle dans un petit un petit
jardin elle va pas loin parce que elle
il y a quelques années de ça il y a une
conductrice qui l'a qui l'a renversé et
donc qui lui a roulé sur le genou droit
donc elle a elle a une
prothèse donc elle va comme tous les
matins promener sa petite chitsou elle
rejoint donc un petit groupe un petit
groupe de mamie qui ont aussi leur petit
chien donc elle reste une petite heure
entre elle et cetera et mercredi dernier
elle donc comme d'habitude elle la
promène et au moment de partir elle
croise une jeune femme cette jeune femme
elle est connue des autres mamies pour
être quelqu'un qui a qui est très
nerveuse elle a un chien un gros chien
c'est un berger australien
elle est connu pour arriver débouler
dire bonjour à personne donc les petites
mamies elles sont toujours assez
inquiètes quand elle arrive moi ma mère
elle elle l'a jamais croisé elle la
connaît pas plus donc ce jour-là elle la
croise
et quand elle la croise elle se jette
sur elle
elle l'attrape par le manteau par les
deux mains elle commence à la secouer la
secouer et puis elle lui dit tu es
qu'une vieille chose je déteste les
vieilles tu qu'une sale vieille elle la
balance en arrière donc ma mère elle
essaie de se rattraper mais elle peut
pas elle tombe sur le trottoir elle se
fracasse le crâne et quand elle se
fracasse le crâne cette femme bon je
sais pas on s'énerve mais on peut faire
on peut avoir un brin d'humanité elle se
dit pas mais qu'est-ce que j'ai fait
rien rien je vais appeler les secours
rien elle reste froide elle la regarde
et puis elle s'en
va donc il y a un monsieur qui est à qui
assiste à la
scène il il va au secours de ma mère
donc il la relève et elle t bien que mal
elle elle elle rentre chez elle alors il
faut savoir que elle vit avec sa sœur
parce que elles ont deux petites
retraites donc elle pour partager le
loyer et heureusement parce que elle
commence à avoir des malaise elle
commence à avoir la bouche qui se tort à
se paralyser tout le côté gauche parce
qu'en fait elle est tombée en plein sur
le le côté droit du cerveau
ici donc sa sœur appelle de suite les
pompiers et les pompiers à 9h30 bon ben
il l'amène aux urgences aux urgences de
Pasteur à
Nice moi je suis appelée à 4h30 pourquoi
4h30 parce que les pompiers n'avaient
pas le bon numéro donc je je suis au
bureau et je reçois un appel des
urgences qui me dit
votre votre maman a été agressée venez
vite son pronostic vital est engagé
venez vite donc je lâche tout j'appelle
mon mari je lui dis Stéphane emmène-moi
emmène-moi vite vite maman a été
agressée emmène mooi on arrive aux
urgences on la voit dans un box
elle est allongé sur le le ventre vous
savez comme pendant le covid on allongé
les personnes âgées pour pas qu'elle
s'étouffe
elle est un légume en train de baver
complètement
inerte donc mon mari la première chose
pose la question il dit mais la police
elle a été avertie donc on lui dit non
bon donc il appelle tout de suite les
flics dit il faut faut venir ma
belle-mère elle est elle est en train de
mourir là faut venir
donc la police arrive ils font les
premières constatations ils me disent
bon mais comment on va faire elle peut
pas elle peut pas parler et
cetera donc moi je suis choquée je ma
mère je je c'était voilà mardi c'était
ça le lendemain c'est c'est un légume
donc le lendemain on retourne à
l'hôpital ça va elle arrive un peu à
parler et elle arrive à nous dire je
suis dis mais maman qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
raconte-nous donc elle nous elle nous
raconte faiblement ce qui s'est passé
avec cette femme qui l'a grippé qui l'a
jeté qui qui l'a insulté qui qui l'a
traité comme un déchet un
déchet donc on appelle tout de suite la
police la brigade criminelle qui a été
prise en qui a pris en charge l'enquête
et je leur dit venez prendre tout de
suite le manteau il y a les empreintes
donc il me disent oui oui pas de
problème on va on va prendre le manteau
on va interroger les caméras parce qu'à
Nice on a beaucoup de
camé donc ils font les enquêtes de
voisinage il ils interrogent les petites
mamie ils arrivent à trouver le nom du
chien de cette monstruosité qui a fait
ça à ma mère et avec les images caméas
donc qui montre les les les photos aux
petites mamie
elle identifie et avec les fichiers
vétérinaires ils arrivent à à retrouver
donc
vendredi la personne qui a fait ça donc
la brigade criminelle l'interpelle
vendredi samedi ma appelle ils me disent
ça y est on a interpellé on l'a
interpellé donc venez on va vous
auditionner parce que comme votre maman
elle peut pas parler bah c'est vous qui
allez parlé à sa place donc ils me
disent voilà elle a été interpellée
vendredi 48 heur de garde à vue donc moi
je raconte tout ce qu'elle m'a dit hein
tous les détails et cetera et elle sera
présentée donc dimanche pour savoir
qu'est-ce qu'on fait sachant que on on
va la présenter pour coup et
blessures
volontaire sur personnes vulnérable avec
circonstances aggravantes ayant entraîné
une infirmité totale permanente je dis
ok donc on arrive le dimanche et le
dimanche donc je vais vous raconter un
peu comment ça s'est passé et comment ça
se passe la justice oui alors ça c'est
important pour noter les spectateurs qui
quand on est Madame personne alors
attendez de petit seconde s parce que
pour ceux qui nous rejoignent à 21h6 là
vous allez nous raconter ce qui s'est
passé avec la justice on vous rappelle
l'affaire Claude 84 ans elle se rend
comme tous les matins dans son petit
jardin se baladaer avec son chien au
moment de rentré une jeune femme avec un
chien beaucoup plus gros que celui de
Claude s'approche d'elle lui disant
qu'elle déteste les vieilles et la
propulce en arrière sa tête tape contre
le sol la jeune femme s'en va laissant
claud par terre qui parvient malgré tout
à se relever avec l'aide d'un passant
elle a encore de l'énergie pour rentrer
chez elle où habite aussi sa sœur une
fois chez elle sa sœur finit par appeler
les pompiers voyant son état se dégrader
fortement une fois à l'hôpital elle
parvient donc à prononcer quelques mots
à sa fille pour lui raconter ce qui
s'est passé la police est prévenue et
grâce à une enquête de terrain et des
caméras de surveillance la jeune femme
est rapidement retrouvée donc la police
a fait un travail excellent grâce au
caméras grâce à la police qui a tout de
suite retrouvé cette jeune femme une
femme de 28 ans qui a un emploi qui
n'est pas connu des services de police
et c'est là que vous allez nous raconter
pour ceux qui nous rejoignent 21h7 ce
qui s'est passé et là on va tous se dire
on marche sur la tête on devient fou
pourquoi la police fait son travail
c'est la question qu'on va se poser là
juste après ça et quand je vois encore
des policiers ce weekend avec qui j'ai
énormément parler ils n'en peuvent plus
les policiers
les policiers n'en peuvent plus ils
disent il voi des gens détresses qui
viennent les voir ils font le boulot ils
le font maintenant pour les gens parce
qu'ils disent on a juste envie aussi de
retrouver pour que vraiment pour que les
gens se sentent mieux qu'on ait retrouvé
le leur agresseur et derrière 24 he
après ils sont dehors donc racontez-nous
vous allez voir c'est hallucinant Sandra
donc ma mère c'est toujours un légume
pronostic vital engagé entre la vie et
la mort oui elle est toujours entre la
vie et la mort
on au mieux ce
sera sera dans un lit
médicalisé au pire ben elle va mourir
elle est en train de
mourir donc je mets les
lunettes la mise en cause est présenté
dimanche le procureur de la République
donc le procureur de la République c'est
qui procureur de la
République c'est quelqu'un qui est censé
représenter la justice représenter la
société vous moi
d'accord lui il demande une une
ouverture d'information d'accord il
sollicite pour cela une juge
d'instruction mais qu'est-ce qui il
requier quoi contrôle judiciaire parce
que pour lui
bah la mise en cause elle a un emploi
elle n'a
pas judiciaire
voilà tout va bien ma mère c'est une
octogénère c'est vrai qu'une victime
octogéère ben dans les
affaires la vie d'une victime
octogénaire ça compte moins que la vie
d'une victime qui a 20 ans 15
ans mais c'est mais am avocate audreé
vazana elle l'a vu c'est je sais pas
voilà c'est c'est c'est c'est voilà
c'est ce qui se passe c'est la vraie vie
hein pas voilà donc lui il demande le
contrôle judiciaire donc contrôle
judiciaire ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que on relâche la personne elle
reprend le cours de sa vie et une fois
par par semaine elle va au commissariat
pointé voilà bonjour merci au revoir
c'est dingue donc un le procureur qui
nous représente tous donc lui il dit ah
allez contrôle judiciaire donc après il
sollicite la juge d'instruction juge
d'instruction elle voit le dossier
elle dit quand même il y a des éléments
grave très grave ah elle ne se prononce
pas elle aurait pu dire moi aussi
contrôle judiciaire non elle dit bon on
va quand même demander la vie d'une
tierce personne le juge des libertés
voilà et là la juge des libertés donc
elle prend le dossier elle dit bon alors
qu'est-ce que vous avez qu'est-ce que
vous qu'est-ce que vous voilà qu'est-ce
que vous proposez donc elle voit la vie
du procureur de la République contrôle
judiciaire donc dit bon ben ok bingo
contrôle
judiciaire et moi donc
lundi avec mon avocate on apprend ça on
apprend qu'elle est dehors depuis hier
soir tranquille qu'elle est rentré à son
travail tranquille pendant que ma mère
là
agoniser le médecin me dit écoutez
madame je sais pas si je sais pas on l'a
mis sous morphine bon vous savez vous
êtes au courant de la fin de vie
qu'est-ce qu'elle veut faire vous êtes
au courant vous en avez un peu parlé
j'ai dis mais attendez ma mère elle
arrête pas de me dire je veux pas mourir
pas mourir j'ai peur j'ai peur j'ai dis
non faut mettre le paquet là oh oh allez
il faut mettre le paquet mais là elle
sait pas partir que je lui ai dit
accroche-toi la police elle l'a arrêté
donc je moi je lui dis pas je lui dis
pas qu'ils l'ont relâché mais ils vont
la tuer elle elle me l'a mis elle me l'a
massacré bien sûr le procureur de la
ville de République à Nice mais il me la
tue il me
l'achève
donc faut savoir dans ces cas-là que le
parquet le parquet donc c'est le
procureur quand il y a une décision
comme ça qui est rendu contrôle
judiciaire ou alors détention provisoire
le parquet il peut faire appel pendant
10 jours donc lundi on est en folie avec
mon avocate on est en folie j'ai dit
mais non c'est pas possible pas possible
merde ouais elle a ouais c'est une
octogénère ouais l'autre elle a rien
elle a pas de casier judiciaire elle a
rien et ouais c'est Madame personne et
alors c'est Madame personne donc on est
Madame personne donc on a droit à une
justice de seconde zone hein ça aurait
été une je sais pas la maman la mamie la
petite mamie d' membre du gouvernement
là ça aurait été la justice Tapier rouge
même pas on se serait posé la question
ça aurait été la détention provisoire
voilà donc on est en folie on est en
folie aussi nous aussi ce soir voà donc
lundi il se passe rien pas d'appel du
parquet mardi pas d'appel du parquet et
là on dit bon on peut pas laisser les
chos dans l'état on commence à alerter
la presse on commence à parler on
commence à faire des des
articles mercredi rien et je dis
aujourd'hui avant de venir chez vous h
donc maître vasana audreé me dit Sandra
ça y est je je sais je je sais qui qui a
dit quoi je sais qui a fait quoi donc
procureur quand on nous dit on va vous
donner une
réponse pénale on va on va on va montrer
qu'on a la justice que on a une réponse
ferme judiciaire mais mais c'est quoi
c'est un dénis de justice c'est
l'injustice totale donc vous tous les
gens là qui sont dans le public vous
êtes comme moi nous on est personne donc
demain il arrive ça à votre maman à
votre mamie ben voilà voilà ce qui vous
attend parce que nous qu'est-ce qu'on a
droit on a droit à une à une justice de
seconde zone et ça ça j'ai dit non je
peux pas laisser passer alors ce sera
pas l'affaire de plus non hein mais
c'est l'affaire de trop et je suis venue
témoigner ce soir hein auprès de vous et
je vous remercie vraiment non mais c'est
moi qui vous remerci pour elle mercira
vous de me donner de me donner euh la au
moins la parole aux victimes c'est très
important votre témoignage SRA moi je
suis à fond avec vous franchement je
pense que tous les gens qui vous ont
regardé ce soir en direct se disent
cette femme est exceptionnelle vous êtes
formidable et vous avez trouvé ma mère
qui exceptionnelle mais vous aussi vous
avez trouvé les mots qu'on cherche tous
depuis des semaines et des semaines je
dis et vous avez nous avez donné un
exemple de de de de ce qu'on ressent
depuis des semaines et des semaines et
la justice française devient
inadmissible je vous le dis quand Éric
dupomorti je vais encore parler de lui
il va je croisé au restaurant la
dernière fois il m' il est pas venu me
voir mais j'aurais bien voulu parler
avec lui Éric Dupont Moretti si on dit
si on s'indigne et qu'on dit que cette
personne là doit aller en prison parce
que ça pour moi c'est tentative tative
de meurtre voilà c'est homicide homicide
et pour moi c'est même homicide
volontaire je suis dés homicide c'est
quand elle elle sera morte heinon m
ouais exactement c'est ça qui est grave
ça veut dire comme on jette une pièce et
on doit savoir si elle est morte non
mais votre mère là elle est dans un état
à vous rendez compte dans l'état dans
lequel est donc ERC dupomoriti il doit
bouger je suis désolé ERC duupomoriti il
doit bouger sur cette affaire j'espère
qu'il nous regarde ce soir il doit
bouger sur cette affaire et montrer la
fermeté la fermeté et que il y a une
certaine fermeté avec la justice et
qu'on peut pas laisser passer ça cette
personne elle peut pas être dehors je
suis désolé c'est inadmissible et je
vais vous dire cette personne dehors
c'est un danger voilà elle typiquement
c'est un danger typiquement elle c'est
un danger voilà je vous dis on a eu deux
qtf tout à l'heure je vous dis pour moi
les deux que j'ai vu c'était pas des
dangers elle cette personne qui est
dehors là pour moi qui c'est un gros
danger et si elle a fait ça à la maman
de Sandra elle le refera je vous le dis
surtout surtout surtout qu'elle a rien
pris je vous le dis elle elle va le
reprendre et et je rajoute un une
dernière chose et je et je le demande à
la justice faites quelque chose parce
que des exemples comme ça c'est le plus
mauvais exemple qu'il puisse avoir vous
croyez qu'il va se passer quoi je le dis
à me mettre du au ministre monsieur
Dupont Moretti il faut bouger vite parce
que de plus en plus il y a des gens qui
vont voir ça vous savez ce qu'ils vont
faire ils vont se faire justi même ils
vont dire moi j'ai vu ce qui se passé
avec la justice vous savez quoi je vais
me faire justice moi-même et il va y
avoir des escalades énormes donc où la
justice tape un grand coup et ça se sert
de cette affaire peut-être euh de de
Claude pour taper un grand coup et pour
revoir peut-être en appel ce qui va se
passer euh voilà et que ça bouge parce
que sinon je vous le dis hein les gens à
force de voir ce qu'il voi à la
télévision dans les journaux sur les
réseaux ils vont dire vous savez quoi
nous on crois plus en la justice donc on
va y aller je vous le dis ça va mal se
terminer et ça va mal se terminer ça va
être règlement de compte sur règlement
de compte on dit merci en tout cas
Sandra d'avoir été avec nous et j'espère
vraiment que ça va bouger vous avez été
incroyable voilà on est avec vous à fond
et on pense fort à Claude surtout et on
lui envoie beaucoup beaup beaucoup de
force merci à tous d'avoir été avec nous
merci à